foreign
[Music]
Google kubernetes engine alternatively
gke control print locks and use them for
troubleshooting some common issues let's
get started with a brief overview of the
gke control plane a gke cluster consists
of a control plane in worker machines
called nodes which together constitute
the kubernetes cluster orchestration
system the controlled entrance processes
such as the kubernetes API server
scheduler and core resource controllers
it is responsible for scheduling and
managing workloads scaling and upgrades
on the nodes managing Network and
storage resources for the workloads the
control plane locks contain the locks
that are emitted by the kubernetes API
server scheduler and core resource
controllers they are stored in Cloud
logging and can be accessed or queried
using log Explorer or the API and I have
great news for those of you who would
like to view control plane logs and
troubleshoot any relevant issues these
locks are now generally available and
you can configure and access them with
standard gke control print versions 1.22
or later be aware gke control print logs
are not available for autopilot clusters
control plane locks can be really useful
in a variety of situations especially
the following diagnosing ongoing
incidents with the workloads or work
curtains for example broken web hooks or
latency issues manifesting as cube
Kettle command timeouts identifying
potential control plane outages for
example you are unable to schedule
workloads or the cluster is inaccessible
you can configure control print logs
using the Google flood console or the
CLI when creating a GK cluster or for an
existing GK cluster by editing the
configuration at any time alright let's
now look at how to enable control print
logs when creating a new cluster go to
the gke Clusters page in the Google
Cloud console create the standard
cluster click the features section go to
operations select API server scheduler
and controller manager components click
OK next let's enable control plane logs
on an existing cluster using the gcloud
CLI
execute this command to update the
cluster and enable log collection
to verify the Locking is enabled execute
this command on the cluster
go to the login section
success the control plane logs are
enabled additionally if you are using
terraform to manage your infrastructure
the logging config block at the
terraform registry for Google container
cluster has details to configure control
plane log collection
let's switch over to Cloud logging in
the Google Cloud console and view the
logs go to the Lux Explorer in Cloud
logging in the resource type section
select kubernetes control plane
component optionally to view logs from
only one control print component use the
component name selector to select only
API server scheduler or controller
manager congratulations you have
successfully enabled and are able to
view control plane logs
now let's look at some real situations
to learn how to debug a GK cluster using
control plane logs WebEx you can use
control plane logs to troubleshoot
issues with webhooks let's go to the GK
cluster page in the Google Cloud console
oops looks like our cluster has no
registration issues a good place to
start debugging this type of issue is
the kubernetes API server so let's check
the control plane logs these messages
indicate that the web Hook is rejecting
requests for the Calico node container
preventing the GK note from becoming
ready this is a common scenario in which
a misconfigured webhook May intercept
calls made by critical system components
operating in the cube system namespace
you can leverage these logs to identify
the misbehaving web hook and then modify
the web configuration to exclude Cube
system resources you can use control
plane logs to troubleshoot control print
latency issues you can inspect the
following fields in API server logs to
learn more about the root cost APF is
API priority and fairness a mechanism to
prevent the control plane from becoming
overloaded latency is a total time for a
request to be processed by the cube API
server APF underscore PL is the name of
the priority level for that flow schema
APF underscore FS is the name of the
flow schema to which the request was
classified APF underscore I seats or APF
underscore fceets are the parameters
that show how heavy we are estimating
the request is APF underscore additional
latency is the duration of the final
stage of the execution of the request
APF underscore execution underscore time
is the time for paid processing the
request without any additional layers
like authentication and APF you can
learn more in the official kubernetes
documentation
finally I'd like to share a useful tip
you can add the trace flag to the
control plane logs to see a detailed
breakdown of the calls including time
consumed for each call remember control
print logs consume the right request per
minute quota of the cloud logging API
great in just a few minutes you'll learn
how to configure an access control plane
logs to troubleshoot your cluster to
learn more about control print logs see
the following documentation thanks for
watching
[Music]